we're joined now by the transport
secretary grant
schaps good morning to you um
can we start off first of all talking
about this uh new
variant uh in brazil how long has the
government known about it
we've known since um sunday when and
japan
uh talks about it it's probably worth
just explaining there are
thousands literally thousands of
different variants of the coronavirus
there's nothing particularly unusual
about hearing
about a new variant uh of course we've
got one right here in the uk as well
um but what we do is we take those
variants
and we put them through a genome
sequencing process in order to find out
the best as we possibly can about them
and this one as with the variant that we
saw in kent or the one in south africa
uh shows it's significantly enough
of interest to us just to take this
precautionary
approach of stopping all those flights
from brazil and south america
uh i would suggest that you're more than
significantly interested to
to ban an entire uh continent and
portugal the the suggestions are that
you have known about the variant for
some time why has it
taken so long to act no no i must just
correct you on this i've heard a couple
of people say it
first of all um what happens with these
variants i heard it with the kent one
you know people said oh you knew about
it since september it took you till
december
people said that that's because when you
sequence these variants it takes a huge
amount of time and science to to do it's
not an
instantaneous thing uh to genome
sequence it
as i say there are about i think there
are 12 000 different variants it's not
unusual
at all and as far as i can see there's
been no flights in the last week
from brazil even if there were people
were required in any case legally to
quarantine
uh from brazil so now we've acted
extremely quickly
given there are 12 000 different
variants of coronavirus
but when we inform the world about the
variant identified in in kent
uh other countries acted almost
immediately to ban
travel from the uk why are we treating
it differently
so the uk has uh carried out the genome
sequencing
of uh nearly half of the entire world's
coronavirus
knowledge if you like so uh we're the
sort of the world's leading
uh country when it comes to that genome
sequencing and you do have to go through
the sequencing to understand
what the what the virus is is doing so
um we we were able with the kent variant
to tell the world straight away this is
exactly what it is
this is what it looks like we've we've
sequenced it
and as soon as we did that we provided
the information to the who
and told other countries um so this is a
bit different this is a this is a
variant from somewhere else
and say there have been thousands of
different variants and takes a little
bit of time to
uh to test that in the meantime everyone
will have had to
quarantine and in any case uh they don't
there weren't direct flights coming from
brazil so
you're saying other countries sorry to
interrupt you're saying that other
countries acted
uh more quickly because we clearly
identified the variant whereas
the variant from brazil hasn't been
clearly identified to you
right so we do a lot of the work in our
own labs um as we did with the south
african variant so to take that one as
an example
um we knew about the variant south
africa knew about the variant
we then got samples of it brought back
to uh to the uk i think to put them down
and then did the analysis uh and uh that
that analysis
um takes days and weeks rather than
hours um to do
but as i say there haven't been flights
coming from brazil in the meantime we've
acted extremely
uh quickly and our scientists aren't
saying that the vaccine won't work
against it
we just want to you know we're at this
late stage now we've we've got so far
we've
got jabs into the arms of three million
uh brits now that's more than france
spain
germany italy put together and we do not
want to be tripping up at this last
moment which is why i took the decision
as an extra precaution uh to ban those
flights entirely
uh reports uh this morning about the
french being concerned about the lateral
flow test and it's its efficacy but but
it's a test that that we
are still prepared to use why is there a
mismatch between what what the
the french deem as uh acceptable
and what we're prepared to accept i
think the report's actually
erroneous i saw that report earlier in
very very close contact with the french
with my opposite number
uh what the french prime minister
actually said was the border workers
would be excluded
uh hauliers are included in that we are
testing
uh julia's um well about 66
000 of them so far your viewers will
remember
that backlogging kent back in december
when the french closed the border before
we
uh put the testing in place um so that
that program is ongoing and
you know for the time being no it's
natural flow testing and the the french
and us work very closely together on
that to make
sure that everybody's tested it's the
world's biggest
testing of lorry drivers anywhere and
we're finding very low
levels of coronavirus something like 0.3
which is much lower than the national
average here or in france and that's
because of course
these lorry drivers long distance
drivers they live in their lorries by
and large they sleep in their cabs it's
actually quite a solitary
uh arrangement and means they're not
very likely to be
carrying the coronavirus around not as
likely as the rest of the population
i wonder if we can go back to the brazil
variant uh you've managed to bring this
ban
in within 24 hours um but
yet still to to confirm the negative
test on on arrival that you announced to
me last
friday what's been the issue there yeah
so with the negative test
which has come in by law but there's
some lenience on it leniency on it until
monday remember that this is actually
um a secondary thing the test because
the first thing is the quarantine which
is required already
and is by law already in place and has
been for a very very long time
but the issue is there are over 200
countries and territories they all have
different types of corona tests
we need to be able to advise accurately
which test people should be able to
must take before they come to the uk and
what we didn't want to do is create a
secondary crisis a repatriation crisis a
brits trying to return
home unsure whether tests in the
particular location they happen to be
uh would be sufficient uh to allow uh
for their
re-entry so uh just for practical
uh for practical purposes to make sure
that brits can return home
uh we've we've provided a little bit of
grace
but everybody coming from anywhere not
on travel corridor
must by law quarantine and there are no
exceptions um to that
and you can end up with a criminal
record if you don't
just to clarify uh just going back um if
i may
with the french border issue are they
not
requiring pcr tests no they do require
pcr tests for uh
people visiting so i think this is where
the confusions come in and by the way
we're in a lockdown nobody should be
moving nobody should be visiting uh in
any case we don't we're not encouraging
uk citizens or anyone in the uk to start
moving around
nationally or internationally but in
addition to that we have this
arrangement with regard to hauliers so
this is so that our goods and services
our food and medicine can carry on
flowing uh across to uh calais and in
that case
um they are able to take uh what are
called lateral flow tests the advantage
being that the test results come within
about 30 minutes
uh and that situation is unchanged in
fact we're welcoming
a delegation from france to the uk today
to actually
um study how we put this process in
place as i say it's the world's biggest
testing of of lorry drivers anywhere in
the world we've done over 66
000 of these tests and we've got a lot
of expertise which they're actually
coming to have a look at today
so british haulers will be totally
unaffected
well i should one thing i should say is
actually 85 percent of julia's
who ply that route are actually european
haulers
so the vast majority are not british
haulers we're mostly
testing actually european haulers in
this particular case
but for the time being there's there's
no change i can't promise what will
happen forever
and a day but um viewers will have
noticed or probably recalled those
scenes of kent being full of lorries
nothing to do with brexit but simply
because
uh the french decided to close their
border
uh when they heard about that uk variant
which is called b117
and uh but we then put this testing in
place that reopened the border and
there'd been no cues
and no disruption uh either through um
the
the covert testing or even indeed the
new paperwork that's uh that's come in
uh at the borders in this last couple of
weeks since that's happened
and we look forward to continuing to see
a smooth operation
down in kent as well grant chaps thank
you very much for
speaking to us this morning